there are thousands of science fiction
stories about robots who are more human
than human but what is it that drives us
to make machines that look like us it
certainly isn't easy one of the hardest
parts is giving humanoid robots
something we take for granted our
ability to walk on two legs robots with
four legs are more stable because more
legs means more points of contact with
the ground and less engineering is
needed to make a workable robot but two
legs provide a sense of familiarity that
helps humans empathize with the machines
teaching robots to walk used to involve
a lot of trial and error robots like as
ammo' took several years of research and
engineering to stand and walk around
with the advent of machine learning
freestanding robots are learning to take
their first steps by training on
thousands of hours of simulations even
before they have legs so we can get them
to stand up but why on earth do we need
upright humanoid robots what can they do
that other robots can't it turns out a
whole lot researchers at the University
of Tokyo are trying to build a complete
human analog of the metal skeleton and
hydraulic muscles their current models
Kenshiro and Ken Goro can perform many
of the same movements as humans
including push-ups and sit-ups aside for
making great bodybuilding coaches the
researchers say they give us insight
into the intricacies of human physiology
but there are some downsides one of
those is psychological
when robots start looking too real they
unsettle us causing us to trust them
less that hasn't stopped scientists from
tackling the daunting task to make
robots look and act more human in 2004
European researchers began work on the
iCub a robot designed to mimic a child
iCub is the hardware that houses the
artificial intelligence software that
powers it the robot can observe its
environment through camera eyes and
microphone ears touch sensors in the
hands and a skin made of printed circuit
capacitors the motivation for creating
iCub is to give AI not only a voice but
also a body iCub has been trained to
observe and respond to its surroundings
by watching humans the robot has learned
to grasp and manipulate objects some of
the project researchers have even taught
it to identify the objects it picks up
but one of i-cubs most valuable lessons
for the field of robotics is in
sociability researchers are training the
robot to maintain eye contact with
humans determine their emotions through
facial expressions and gestures and
respond to nonverbal communication in
order to complete tasks this kind of
research could mark the beginning of a
new era in human robot interactions but
what about those science fiction dreams
one day we'll ask the robots what they
think
[Music]
you